In this video, we'll look at some additional tips and
tricks for OSC as well as point to
some resources you can utilize when
implementing OSC for your own projects.
Some tips and tricks we used before
is actually to convert everything to strings.
As we know in Unreal Engine,
almost every types of
variable is able to be converted into a string.
So for example, in the screenshot we showed here,
we are sending two different OSC messages,
all using just three string values.
So on the left side, we see we're sending things like
Dickens and a full value and
the Boolean value all converted into strings.
On the right-hand side, we're again sending one string value,
one integer value converted to string,
and one more enum converted to string.
So that's just an easy way for us to
quickly utilize the same event over and over,
but sending various types of values.
Do note strings are
a more expensive data type than something like a Boolean,
which I believe is only one byte.
Strings can be much, much more.
So if you do run into issues with bottlenecking for data,
then perhaps strings are not the best choice.
In these examples, we're utilizing functions which
take in strings and other data that are necessary,
and then within the function that data is sent over OSC.
As previously mentioned, it's important to use
unique names for both your server and your clients.
Anything with the same name will actually override each other,
not unlike when you have input set to be consumed,
in which case here if two things have the same name,
then only the second one that is
created would work and the original earlier one would not.
So just again, reminder,
give everything a unique name.
Another reminder to a similar issue.
For OSC server, we need to make sure
each port only has one OSC server listening to it.
If we have two OSC server listening to
the same port and live in say in a different actor,
but they are both in the same level,
it might encounter issues that
only one server is able to listen to it,
and the other is not able to receive anything.
Make sure that each port only has one listen server
that's listening to the messages.
Lastly, certainly don't feel the need to type these indirectly.
Go to the slide and use these links to visit other resources,
including Unreal Engine documentation
to learn more about OSC implementation,
as well as just websites such as opensoundcontrol.stanford.edu,
which will tell you more about the history of the protocol.
You'll also see under the documentation section
links to more information about the OSC plugin,
how to use OSC with switchboard for virtual production,
utilizing OSC with Python,
as well as audio options specific to Blueprint and OSC.
We hope you have found this course useful and wish you luck
implementing OSC for all of your project needs. Good luck.
Thank you.